[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre set
loisirs à vis de vous retrouver pour un
plein d'idées de sorties le sommaire de
ce jeudi 31 janvier des chiffres des
mots et des images chocs sur les
inégalités femmes hommes
l'exposition soyons affiche est
consacrée aux femmes a ouvert ses portes
le 30 janvier reportage dans son numéro
depuis quatre ans le conservatoire de
montigny le bretonneux créer un
orchestre et invite un chef d'orchestre
pour le diriger et sont une quarantaine
de musiciens avons donné rendez vous
pour leur concert symphonique et puis
nous quitterons si les événements fin
d'édition pour une exposition
elle entend expliquer les sept unités
universel et fondamentales permettant de
quantifier notre monde
le musée des arts et métiers explore le
thème de la mesure sous toutes ses
formes et à travers le temps une manière
ludique de réviser ses repères depuis
huit ans la ville de guyancourt consacre
un mois aux femmes le temps des femmes a
commencé le 30 janvier et s'étend
jusqu'au 24 mars
plusieurs animations une exposition pour
afficher la lutte contre les inégalités
femmes hommes
aucune femme dans les 15 personnalités
préférées des français
les objets ne sont pas des femmes l'un
vers sont plus des chiffres des slogans
des visuels chocs dans le cadre de son
temps des femmes
la ville de guyancourt se pose la
question l'égalité où en est on l'idée
étant de réunir des artistes autour sa
thématique là de l'égalité avec l'envi
en tout cas de montrer les divers
supports du dic du discours féministe
aujourd'hui que ce soit du street art
comme avec les oeuvres de mystique qui
sont juste derrière moi on va voir aussi
de la vidéo de la fiche de
l'illustration aussi du dessin de presse
d'autres aussi toutes les formes que
prend que prendre le discours autour
l'égalité aujourd'hui une dizaine
d'artistes ont répondu à l'appel parmi
eux arnaud corbin il interpelle le
public avec des chiffres chocs sur des
visuels
je milite et je m'engage pour que pour
que le monde qui nous entoure et put les
gens avec qui on travaille pic de soi
même on essaye d'être respectueux ils
vivent dans un monde un tout petit peu
plus tranquille tout petit peu plus
harmonieux un tout petit peu plus
respectueux l'exposition soyons affiché
est au centre de ce mois consacré aux
femmes et entraîne avec elle de
nombreuses animations pour toucher un
public le plus large possible
on a aussi des débats on a aussi au
théâtre notre ferme de bel ébat notre
centre culturel il ya aussi des
représentations théâtrales et on a aussi
une forte chaque année une forte
sensibilisation envers les enfants et
les plus jeunes et il ya plus de 300
jeunes qui se sont inscrits pour venir
avec laurent enseignants visiter
l'exposition et puis aussi travailler et
c'est ça qui est le plus important
travailler sur le sujet de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
depuis le 1er janvier 2019 16 femmes
sont décédées sous les coups de leur
conjoint ou ex conjoint en france
il noté qu une vie guidée en présence
des artistes aura lieu le samedi 7
février 11 heures en france seuls 4% des
concerts sont dirigées par des femmes
et justement ce dimanche 3 février à
montigny le bretonneux vous pourrez
profiter du concert symphonique du
conservatoire dirigé par une femme avec
nous en plateau antoine boesch vous êtes
le directeur du conservatoire de
montigny le bretonneux bonjour bonjour
alors depuis quatre ans un orchestre est
reconstituée au conservatoire et vous
invitez un ou une chaude une chef
d'orchestre elle dirige et comment ça se
passe alors cette année on est ravi
d'avoir laetitia trouver qui vient
diriger cet orchestre symphonique
on a eu effectivement souhaité faire
venir des chefs différents invités des
chefs comme ça se fait sur les grands
orchestres et là on a les amateurs et
qui trouve à la fois justement des
façons de travailler différente des
sensibilités différentes
et cette année c'est donc sous la
baguette de laëtitia trouver laetitia
trouver comment vous les choisissez à
chaque fois les chefs d'orchestre alors
c'était un réseau à la fois de deux
chefs sur les orchestres et aussi c'est
important d'avoir des chefs qui sont à
la fois comme laetitia trouver quelqu'un
qui dirige des grands orchestres
professionnels et qui dirige à la fois
des orchestres amateurs et aussi des
orchestres se met professionnels là ça
sera vos élèves du conservatoire c'est
une sacrée expérience pour eux d'être
dirigé par une grande chef d'orchestre
oui c'est absolument incroyable pour eux
c'est beaucoup beaucoup d'exigences le
travail en session comme on parlera
peut-être est intéressant puisque il ya
six répétition donc quasiment comme des
conditions professionnelles
les élèves travaillent les partitions
avant et découvre le chef est aussi
répétitions doivent monter des oeuvres
pour le concert travail en session ça
veut dire savons fessiers répétition ça
veut dire que les élèves ont travaillé
avant et on fait un enchaînement de
répétition en tout hic c'est à dire avec
tous les musiciens ou en partiel avec
uniquement les cordes uniquement les
vents est effectivement aussi répétition
doit arriver à monter un programme à peu
près un programme d'une demi-heure et
qu'elle fera t-il ce programme alors
alors trois oeuvres au programme une
pièce de scènes de schubert une pièce
d'ottorino respighi pour une suite danse
et des anciens est aussi une pièce
composée pour un film dien ben phu par
le compositeur georges delerue combien
ils sont deux musiciens à participer
alors il ya à peu près une quarantaine
de musiciens sachant que en amont dans
ce concert en amont de cet orchestre
symphonique
on a aussi des orchestres d'élèves un
peu plus petit des orchestres d'harmonie
donc une heure de concert en tout donc
si on parle un peu du conservatoire
c'est un gros conservateur à montigny le
bretonneux vous avez plusieurs
enseignements avec le théâtre aussi
absolument alors le contraire at war est
au sein d'une structure qui s'appelle le
pôle musique théâtre qui inclut le
conservatoire une école de théâtre et
des studios de répétition et
d'enregistrement
donc là ce week-end on a concert
symphonique à d'autres rendez-vous à
attendre alors oui on a plusieurs
rendez-vous à lors des grands rendez
vous donc à la ferme du manet comme
effectivement ce concert symphonique où
le concert d éveil sur la fin de l'année
l'année dernière c'était un opéra pour
enfants avec un orchestre professeurs et
puis tout au long de l'année différents
projets en musique en théâtre musique et
théâtre puisque les croisements entre
les disciplines est une
un des points forts de ce pôle musique
théâtre merci d'antoine bauza devenu has
made plateau donc la quatrième édition
du concert symphonique ce dimanche 3
février à 15 heures à la ferme du manège
un salon du jeu vidéo s'installe pour la
première fois au mini le roi samedi 2
février de mario à dragon ball z en
passant par fifa tous les univers seront
représentés pour des parties enflammées
et pour ceux qui voudraient être leur
propre héros de jeu vidéo ils pourront
tester la réalité virtuelle dans un
espace dédié
en 2015 les éditions bloomsbury la
maison d'édition montée harry potter
lancée la nuit
harry potter depuis chaque 1er jour du
mois de février
frère célèbre le sorcier à cicatrices le
centre alfred de vigny participent à la
fête et vous propose de passer le test
du choix peau pour entrer à poudlard 7
février à 19h30 rattraper le biopic à
succès vous découvrir la dernière
comédie très attendue
c'est votre rendez vous dans les salles
saint-quentinoise luc beaucamp directeur
du cies 17 à elancourt et au micro de
patrick j'étais dixmude cette semaine au
ciné c'est un large éventail de films à
voir ou à revoir jeudi à revoir parce
que toujours à la fiche bohemian
rhapsody le film phénomène qui raconte
une partie de la vie du groupe bull et
de son honneur donc toujours à l'affiché
des cas les gens il est déjà venu voir
quatre cinq six fois donc on continue à
diffuser ne viendra plus
et puis surtout centré nationale très
attendue paraît-il
qu'est-ce qu'on a encore fait au bon
dieu avec christian clavier le talon
donc succès attendu de l'année 2019 mais
aussi la mule le très bon thriller on va
dire sentimentale de clint eastwood
qu'on n'avait pas vu à l'écran 88 ans
clint eastwood avait pas vu à l'écran
depuis longtemps dont il reprend son
rôle un peu de personnages boubou qui
n'en fait qu'à sa tête
c'est assez savoureux et puis aux 6 à
pickering
alors ça c'est qu'un film qui raconte
l'histoire de la vie d'oscar wilde et il
passe pour très peu de salles
venez le voir sa fille de rupert everett
qu'on n'ait pas eu le cinéma depuis
longtemps avec toute perte everett et
pour les plus petits en avant-première
dimanche matin à 10h30 le très attendu
aussi ralph et gow 3 0 est aussi le très
joli
japonais mirail ma petite soeur sur nos
écrans restons dans les salles obscures
tout en partant à l'aventuré lors du
dernier vendée globe
éric bellion a embarqué avec lui une
caméra miniature plus de 50 heures
d'enregistrement pour en faire un film
d'une heure 25 immersion totale dans ce
tour du monde en solitaire
la sortie officielle de comme un seul
homme et le 13 février prochain
le navigateur le présenter en avant
première à l'ugc cyrano de versailles le
24 janvier dernier michael et demi
d'euros et patrick jacques de dixmude
donc c'est tout ce qui se passe quand on
perd le bateau de vue et jusqu'à ce
qu'on le redécouvre et donc c'est tout
ce cheminement intérieur le fait d'aller
au delà de sa peur de se rencontrer et
j'essaie de le raconter avec le plus de
sincérité possible je crois que des
moments très forts parce que ça c'est
une aventure ultime
moi j'avais jamais fait de solitaire
avant de partir sur le vendée globe
donc tout est une découverte chaque jour
est une aventure
[Musique]
vision mondiale mois
bado heureux vous rendez vous au bord du
terrain du week end du basket dans le
championnat de nationale 3 l'équipe
féminine du chesnay versailles reçoit ce
dimanche 3 février l'union sportive la
glacerie
une rencontre capitale elles sont
actuellement à la première place du
classement avec deux points d'avancé sur
les seconds du parquet au gaz ou dans le
championnat honneur de rugby versailles
reçoit coussin ville pour la 12e journée
les versaillais tenteront de rester
invaincu depuis ce début de saison pour
les supporter c'est au stade mont boron
ce dimanche à 15 heures partons à 31
kilomètres de nos studios pour une
exposition toute en mesure le musée des
arts et métiers se propose de nous
expliquer de façon ludique les sept
unités universelle est fondamentale
l'exposition sur mesure les sept unités
du monde est à visiter jusqu'au 5 mai un
reportage de paul bloqué de nos
confrères via grand paris
ce n'est pas qu'une question poids dans
la balance du système international
les unités de mesure sont au nombre de
sept comme les merveilles du monde
elles sont regroupées au musée des arts
et métiers pour une exposition ludique
et historique entre appareils de mesure
d'une autre époque et interaction
directe avec le visiteur
ce rendez vous est destiné à tous les
publics amateurs scientifique ou simples
curieux car l'objectif est important
l'exposition dès le départ a été fait
pour un large public
il va de soi que des spécialistes se
trouveront à certains endroits matière à
à comprendre certaines choses mais
l'idée c'est de s'adresser vraiment à
tout le monde pour faire comprendre
cette place de la mesure et l'importance
notamment de définir ensemble les mêmes
unités
on ne pourrait échanger on ne pourrait
commercer entre pourrait faire de la
science que si l'on parle tous le même
langage qu'on utilise les mêmes unités
divisé en plusieurs salles l'exposition
nous plonge d'abord dans un quotidien
sur mesure de la balance de la salle de
bain au compteur de la pompe à essence
tout est mise en scène pour bien
comprendre que ces unités de mesure
entourent tous les jours puis place à
l'histoire avec des objets parfois
démesurées comme cette machine à
statistiques ancêtres de l'ordinateur
l'exposition de diversifier c'est une
exposition où l'on va apprendre des
choses saisi 1 ce qu'est la place de la
mesure mais en se faisant plaisir parce
que on va voir de très belles choses il
ya un cabinet de curiosités il y à des
objets rares il y a de quoi
s'émerveiller
je crois que c'est du plaisir qui va
nous amener à de la connaissance pour
comprendre et les unités de mesure tout
en se divertissant
le musée des arts et métiers vous donne
rendez vous jusqu'au 5 mai prochain
et c'est la fin de votre 7,8 choisir
merci nous avoir suivis pour ce week-end
n'oubliez pas d'acheter du lait pour
faire sauter les crêpes de la chandeleur
bonne semaine sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh